Speaker 1: As I've been telling you all week,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, Republican congresswoman,
now wants to be taken seriously. And
unfortunately, it's looking increasingly
like corporate media is going to help her. There's
a really good article in Salon by Amanda marcotte,
which makes a lot of the points that we've been
making on the show this week about Marjorie
Taylor. GREENE And Amanda writes, quote. Marjorie
Taylor GREENE wants to be a mainstream Republican
now. Sadly, the media will let it happen. GREENE
is walking the path laid by the Tea Party in which
today's extremists become tomorrow's new
GOP normal. This is a really good article,
and it points out a few different things. One of
them is that there's no real daylight between the
two factions. In other words, the two factions
we're talking about are the pro Kevin McCarthy,
pro-Trump people and the anti Kevin McCarthy
pro-Trump people. Remember, as I told you
yesterday and the day before, you used to have
pro and anti-Trump Republicans. The anti-Trump
Republicans are still there, but now the pro-Trump
Republicans have divided into two. The ones that
wanted Kevin McCarthy to be speaker and the
ones that did not. Amanda marcotte writes in
this article that there is a very good chance that
corporate media is going to allow Marjorie Taylor
GREENE to rebrand herself in this way that she
is trying to do. It's extraordinarily important
that we not be fooled by this redemption tour of
sorts that Marjorie Taylor GREENE now is on her
perspective is now that Kevin McCarthy is speaker.
I voted for the speaker. Republicans are in power.
I can either go the way of being kind of one of
these agitators like Lauren Boebert, who she's
very much in a war with at this point in time.
Or I can be cozy with power. I can get back on
committees. And that's very appealing to Marjorie
Taylor GREENE. She is clearly desperate for power.
And part of this may even be starting to think
about continuing to lobby to be Donald Trump's
vice presidential running mate. The other thing
and this is not about, oh, everyone's a fascist.
That's not what I'm saying. But when we think
about authoritarianism and fascist wannabes and
dictator wannabes, fascists will often do these
rewriting of their own history, realignments,
these sort of redemption tours. If you allow them
to do it, they will sort of mention some of my
past views were either mistakes or jokes, which I
regret. Marjorie Taylor GREENE did that on Sunday,
where she said, I got sucked into some stuff
on the Internet, like it happens to everybody.
And if you allow them, they will rewrite their
own history. Marjorie Taylor GREENE is desperate
for power. She's desperate for credibility and
recognition. After being a joke removed from
committees and essentially a laughingstock
for two years. And she's probably angling
for some position of higher power. It could be
within Congress. It could be as Donald Trump's
running mate. She wants to go from Jewish space
lasers to I'm normal. I fell for some stuff, but
please forgive me. Now. I'm really a mainstream
Republican, just like Mitt Romney or something
like that. Corporate media should not allow her to
get away with that. And I have been careful when
we talk about George W Bush and I say, listen,
if you put up a video of George W Bush and you
put up a video of Trump, obviously George W Bush
seems normal compared to Trump. But let's not
allow his reputation to be rehabilitated. When he
did horrible things as president and the media,
corporate media should not allow Marjorie Taylor
GREENE to get away with what she is very obviously
trying to do. Like Amanda marcotte writes, I'm
worried they will let her get away with it,
but let's hope it doesn't happen. Plastic is
everywhere we look and not enough is being
done about it. 100 billion plastic bags are used
and thrown away every year. But you can help make
a change. Our sponsor hold on makes trash and
kitchen bags that are heavy duty plant based,
nontoxic and 100% home compostable, which means
they break down in weeks rather than decades. They
don't fill up our landfills. They don't pollute
our oceans. Their zip seal kitchen bags come in
sandwich or gallon bags sizes to fit your needs.
And the best part about hold on bags is they work.
I use them at home. They're just as good as
all of the name brand bags. You fill them up.
They stretch and they don't break. Everybody uses
trash bags and freezer bags. If you care about the
planet, you can do something by using hold on bags
instead. And it's a really easy way to do your
part. Go shop plant based bags to replace single
use plastics all over your home. You'll save 20%
when you go to hold on bags dot com slash pacman
and use the code pacman. The link is down below.